you've lost your friend and co-founder
you must be devastated
yes you can imagine it's been a tragic
week and a lot of emotions running high
it's been difficult for me uh watching
this from afar I can't even imagine what
it was like for the families of the crew
or the Ocean Gate team that's been
working hard to try saving the crew all
week
when you heard that contact was lost did
you think it was likely they were stuck
they were waiting for rescue or did you
think it was more probable that what did
happen happened
well I as as you mentioned I haven't
been with the company for 10 years but I
know that throughout our operations we
followed standard lost com protocols so
there are systems in place and
procedures in the place for what to do
when a sub does lose contact with the
surface so at the moment when I first
heard that I thought Stockton it was the
pilot would have just followed standard
protocol and uh and surfaced the sub
did Stockton always go on board
uh not always he was the chief subpilot
but uh remember this company's uh 14
years old we've gone through three uh
three sub models in the Titan
development program starting with
antipodes and then going to Cyclops and
then ultimately to Titan and along the
way we added multiple different
subpilots in fact I did 72 Dives um
antipodes before I left the company in
January 2013.
it's reported
um that several former employees raised
concerns about the safety of that
particular vessel
um did Stockton take that on board I
mean to go on it himself repeatedly
he must have been pretty confident in
the safety
uh yeah that's that's the thing about
Stockton you know he was a he was a
talented engineer he's very intelligent
person who's a passionate Explorer but
mostly he was a keen risk manager he was
very well aware of the risks of
operating at these deep depths and he
was very committed to safety and uh
every Innovation that he made as an
engineer or in the dive operations in
his mind was really pushing two things
number one is expanding the capabilities
of humanities ability to explore the
devotions but also to ensure that it was
done as safely as possible
but when these uh concerns were raised I
I acknowledge that you you left the
company some years ago but knowing him
and knowing how the company worked that
you co-founded would those concerns have
been taken on board and investigated
yeah I did keep them even though I left
the company in January 2013. I I did
keep in touch with Stockton uh talked
with him probably on a monthly basis in
fact the last time I talked with him was
two weeks before this current expedition
of the Titanic and one thing that always
impressed me about Stockton is uh as
intellectual as he was he was and
opinionated as it was uh as are most
folks in this uh in this community uh he
was always willing to listen to other
people's uh opinions and evaluate them
and if you could convince him he was
willing to change his mind which is
which is fairly rare in this kind of
field
the particular employee that raised
concerns about the safety says that he
was dismissed
after that uh do you have any any
perspective on that
uh no first of all that happened after I
left the company and secondly I wasn't
privy to any of the underlying facts
behind that
you're still a minority shareholder
aren't you Guillermo um of Ocean Gate
can it survive this
uh that is a very good question and I'm
sure that's what
um the board of directors will be
considering
um in the coming weeks I think right now
the focus is going to be on consoling
the families of the crew members and uh
to help the like I said earlier the team
that spent four days hoping that they
could find the their teammates and
rescue them it must be a difficult time
for them and I'm sure they're going to
be spending uh you know the next few
days weeks months uh getting over this
yeah I mean the families will clearly
need consoling they'll also have a lot
of questions won't they not least about
safety procedures I understand they had
to sign pretty stringent
waivers
um
do you suspect that that that covers
the company that they signed away they
said yes we know that we're taking a
risk or do you think the company may be
somehow liable for negligence
yeah that's clearly a question of not
qualified answer not only am I not
working at the company I'm not a legal
counsel so I'd refer to them what I do
know is every single person who went on
any of our Expeditions uh joined us as
full members of the crew they signed up
as Mission Specialists they went through
training they participated in the dive
operations on the surface and they had
active roles as participants during the
Dives I'm even though I never went on
one of these Titanic Expeditions I know
that was the intent behind each of these
and everyone who came on as an explorer
was very proud of the fact that they
were not passengers but no not tourists
that they were actually active members
of the crew uh fulfilling a science and
research Expedition
to your knowledge does the company have
insurance
that's something I'm I have no knowledge
to to answer I'm sorry
where does it leave do you think the
future for commercial deep sea
exploration
well I think
um
this is a very small Global Community
most of us know each other uh and we
respect each other generally each
other's opinions even if we disagree
with them uh and one of the things that
concerns all of us is these differences
of opinion uh may lead to people doing
things differently in different
capacities and every time someone
operates in a in an unforgiving
environment like this you run the risk
of something going catastrophically
wrong and uh you hope that it doesn't
happen for for those folks but you also
uh hope that it doesn't tarnish the the
image of ocean exploration in general
and given that it is a small community
to your knowledge or other companies
that are offering similar things have
they have they paused their missions
uh that I don't know and I'm not um I'm
not privy to tell any of that
information
and I also understand that Stockton had
Visions Beyond uh just taking people to
do to see the Titanic he wanted to work
with oil and gas companies and really
push commercial deep sea exploration
into lots of different areas is that
right
yeah and I think that's where it's
important to separate out the sub itself
from the business model uh when Stockton
and I co-founded the company in 2009 Our
intention was to create a small Fleet of
works of mercifuls that could take black
people down at least four thousand maybe
six thousand meters and make them
available to anybody who needed them
whether that was researchers explorers
tourists filmmakers energy companies
military uh the whole intent is to
create these work uh subs and in that
way as our tagline was in the early days
open the oceans for all of humanity
and so you think commercial exploration
like this can survive
I would hope so for a number of
different reasons number one is that
it's an important Endeavor and Humanity
needs it to continue but also to
preserve the legacy of these five crew
members who were all true explorers and
unfortunately died something that they
were passionate about and believed in